assalamo alaikom guys I usually think
about this I want to share with you
anytime about the check out we're
finishing up at the hotel room and you
know sometimes you get a little situated
at the hotel room and you get
comfortable you're you're able to get
some work done maybe relax a little bit
especially you got a nice room but then
it's time to check out it's time to
check out you do a sweep you know you
get your stuff ready and it's time to go
and you're just like okay it's time to
check out I gotta get out of here but
you can't help but feel like okay maybe
some people you develop a attachment a
small attachment I actually had a nice
stay there and I relate that to life now
imagine if I really started to decorate
this place I really started bringing my
own paintings and rearranged things
bought some furniture and then it was
time to go check out time well that's
the thing that we need to really think
about checkout time for life we're gonna
have to leave this life sooner or later
and we got to remember that checkout
date we can't forget that it's coming
soon and that's the beautiful thing
about this Dean the blessing that a loss
want Allah the Almighty the Creator has
given us you know the answers to life
and everything we need to prepare for
the checkout date the date that we're
gonna have to check out from this life
it's not a call to be pessimistic but to
be optimistic that if we planted seeds
of goodness now we were productive we
did good we were good human beings and
we helped others we motivated others to
do what was morally right we're gonna
make mistakes man nobody's a walking
angel on earth but you worship their
Creator not the creation you Dudhwa done
was morally right come to mojito Oh
Martin oh hey Jelena see Tom O'Donovan
model fee were 10 Helena in Mullica what
took me know nothing that you were the
best OMA raised up for mankind you
enjoin what is right you forbid what is
wrong and you believe in Allah so you're
doing this but it comes with the
responsibility are we doing it are we
inviting the good forbidden was evil and
implementing this Deen in our life
preparing for the checkout date the same
way you're gonna check out the hotel
we're gonna have to check out of this
life and it's either genom
Jenna let's get to Jenna brothers and
sisters let's not get too caught up in
this short life that we have compared to
the millions of millions that I save
millions trillions no losses eternity in
Jenna for those who believe and do
righteous good deeds alright you made
some mistakes don't worry about it Allah
is most loving and merciful
turn back repent and get ready for
checkout date don't get too caught up
with the dunya coz the dunya are gonna
have to leave behind thank you hope you
benefit from this reminder this was
something that was going through my mind
before my check out here Salaam alaikum
peace be with you